good morning everybody happy monday to  everyone right now no major crashes to  report on our  major roadways you can still get out and  smooth sailing get to where you need to  be  in a perfect time but here is an update  to a crash that happened overnight  this was actually two different crashes  the first was an auto pedestrian  crash a hit and run and then that same  driver  ran a red light and caused a crash and  then has died and you can see  that they're still lane closures they're  still investigating the situation right  now  and of course coming up we're going to  give you updates around some other areas  around our valley